your private life is
so so hidden
so out of reach from the masses from the
public
i mean who you are outside of the
business
what you are outside of the business
it's it's a high level of unknown
you know it's really what you choose to
allow people to see
have you have you managed to control
that narrative
in a way where it's honestly just in
your favor like and even in times today
where it can't sway where people can dig
it's never been a question
and there's only a few there's only a
few that actually have done that you are
one of the few i i honestly think it's a
mix of
uh me trying to protect it and be really
careful about
what i do and where i go and
and people not giving a [ __ ] it's that
and people don't care what do you mean
people don't i mean you know i i've had
paparazzi follow me and then they and
then they're like
you know you're not gonna do nothing i'm
like i'm at the store
yeah i'm gonna buy some eggs yeah and
i'm gonna go over there and i'm gonna
get some broccoli they're like this
that's it they don't care it's not
exciting i'm not
there's nothing out there to really like
watch i'm really a dude from the midwest
who came from a family with two parents
and you know
a dog and a very kind of basic boring
[ __ ] there's not a whole lot and i kind
of created that
with my life i have a wife my kids are
grown now we
okay so i'm not out there in the streets
to be a part of a lot of stuff that
people would want to know a lot of stuff
and i also think as an actor it kind of
helps
to be less known because then i think
it's easier for people to believe you in
the roles you're in because they're not
like oh no that's that dude that that
they're like i don't really know who
that dude is he's a cipher a little bit
you know what's crazy and i don't even
want to say it's kind of an old-school
uh way of thinking
because it's true right what you just
said is it's so true
and it makes sense and i've heard the
denzels of the world say it i've heard
the samuel
jacksons of the world say it you know i
hear you now saying it
that less is more from what you give to
the public uh
do you feel like the changes that have
come with the times today
uh is it is it better in your opinion
for the younger generations of actors
and actresses
that are coming up that are allowed and
able to give so much more
right to their fan base do you like that
side of it or do you not like it i don't
i mean well now it's like it's almost
required like
like they're they cast people off of if
they have
instagram followers what they're
following is they're not you know that
gives them an edge over another actor in
a role
so that's something that's completely
brand new to me and that they're
expected to
participate in that in a way that's not
just like like we do a press junket it's
not that it's like oh you need to post
this
you need to make sure you get on this on
instagram you need to tweet this out
so there's a huge public facing you know
part of
actors personas that had nothing to do
with anything that
when we came up now we are a part of it
too and we're asked to do the same
things and take it back
we're already established at this point
so for people just coming up like i had
a
kid asking me today like what do i do
how do i start i'm trying to get out
there
i was like i have no idea because we
used to audition for people
yeah we'd go in a room yeah and i'm
pretty sure i wasn't in those rooms with
you but i'm pretty sure you knew how to
win the room
absolutely so i would know how to win
the room that was that was a part of the
audition that was
that was for me the audition and i'd win
the room and i'd be like oh yeah now
let's do these words
and by the time you did the words
they're already they're already into you
so they're trying to figure out a reason
to say yes as opposed to an excuse to
say no and now when they look at tape
it's the exact opposite
it's they're trying to exclude people
yeah so when people at when young actors
say what do i do to start i'm like dude
i have no idea i really couldn't tell
you you said you're from the the midwest
where you from the
uh kansas city missouri kansas city
missouri outskirts or inner city what
city the city uh mom dad you said
a dog no brothers no sisters yep brother
and sister really a middle kid
younger brother older sister uh are they
cooler
than you i think most people would say
that
i would believe it yeah i mean it's not
hard to imagine right now i'm not saying
it in a negative way but i can
definitely see
i can definitely see them just being a
yeah i get it a cooler i mean i'm
wearing a vest
they got to be cooler than me right i
wasn't going to say it right well dime
right kevin that's aggressive i know
what you're doing what do you mean it's
aggressive
i know what you're doing because i lean
forward yeah my back hurts yeah
you've done this before okay i'm just
going to say there's an old friend i
think you
were attuned to each other absolutely
right yeah by the way nice vests
i appreciate that ask me what suit it
goes to
what suit does it go you have no idea no
idea
it was a costume from a show i did yeah
you just took it i
took it you took it i took it
you